okay
like check one two one two testing one
two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten like check one two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten mic check one two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten mic check one two
three four
foreign
you
you
good afternoon today the supreme court
heard arguments in a case
that could strike down the affordable
care act in its entirety
if the supreme court agrees with the
opponents of the act
their decision could take health care
away
from 20 million americans it could take
away protections for more than 100
million people
with pre-existing conditions in our
country and hurt the millions of
americans
who have come to rely on the affordable
care act
getting rid of the affordable care act
will take us backward
to a time when people could charge a
woman more for
her health care than they could charge a
man simply because
she's a woman to a time when pregnancy
could be considered a pre-existing
condition
it will take away free birth control and
contraceptive coverage for women
this is all happening at a moment when
our country is suffering through a
pandemic
that has claimed more than 238
000 lives and we all know that if the
affordable care act is struck down
communities of color would be hit
particularly
hard black asian hispanic and native
american
because they are at a greater risk of
pre-existing conditions from asthma
to diabetes to lupus and they are also
three times as likely to contract
covid19
and twice as likely to die as others
now i know we all know that we just had
an election
in america an election where health care
was very much
on the ballot our country had a clear
choice in this election each and every
vote
for joe biden was a statement that
health care in america
should be a right and not a privilege
each and every vote for joe biden was a
vote
to protect and expand the affordable
care act
not to tear it away in the midst of a
global pandemic
and joe biden won the election
decisively
with more votes than have ever been cast
in american history
it amounts to 75 million
voices and counting calling on the
supreme court
to see this case for what it is
a blatant attempt to overturn
the will of the people and the
president-elect
and i cannot let that happen
and now it is my honor to introduce
president-elect joe biden
thank you good afternoon everyone
this morning as was stated the united
states supreme court heard oral
arguments
on the case of grave importance to the
american people
this case represents the latest attempt
by the far-right ideologues to do what
they've been repeatedly failed to do
for a long time in the courts in the
congress and the court of public opinion
over the last decade to eliminate the
entirety of the affordable care act
twice already the supreme court has
upheld the landmark law
in 2012 and again in 2015.
and the congress expressing the popular
will of the american people on a
bipartisan basis
has rejected numerous attempts numerous
efforts by president trump
to erase the law as well now in the
middle of a deadly pandemic
that has infected more than 10 million
americans
nearly one in every 32 americans
often with devastating consequences to
their health
these ideologues are once again trying
to strip
health coverage away from the american
people the goal
of the outgoing administration is clear
from the brief they filed in the supreme
court it asserts and i quote
the entire aca thus must
fall end of quote now
i'm not naive about the fact that health
care is an issue that has divided
americans in the past
but the truth is the american people are
more united on this issue today
than they are divided recently as last
month a leading survey found that
american people want to keep the
affordable care act in place
by an overwhelming margin of 58 to 36
percent
79 of the american people including nine
out of 10 democrats
eight out of ten independents and two
thirds of republicans
want to keep the aca protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
which would be eliminated if this
lawsuit were to succeed
this doesn't need to be a partisan issue
it's a human issue it affects every
single american family
we can't subvert the growing consensus
the american people
based on an argument put forward in the
briefs seeking to invalidate the law
that even many conservative legal
scholars including in the national
review consider to be quote ridiculous
let's be absolutely clear about what's
at stake
the consequence of the trump
administration's argument are not
academic or an abstraction for many
americans they are a matter of
life and death in a literal sense this
argument will determine whether health
care coverage
of more than 20 million americans who
acquired an earned affordable care act
will be ripped away in the middle of the
nation's worst pandemic
in a century over 100 million people as
the vice president-elect
pointed out over 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions
like asthma diabetes cancer could once
again be denied coverage
whether complications from 19 like
lung scarring and heart damage will be
the next flood of pre-existing
conditions
that can be used as an excuse to jack up
premiums
or deny coverage altogether for millions
of survivors
who have struggled won and fought
the co the coronavirus fought against
the loss of their life
this argument is going to determine
whether women as is pointed out
will once again be charged higher
premiums just because they're women
or seniors will see their prescription
drug costs
go up and like kids who
whether or not they can stay on their
parents plan solay's 26th
where their annual lifetime benefits
will be
reimposed so someone could walk in and
say
die in peace you run out of your
coverage
this isn't hyperbole it's real as real
as it gets
when the family is faced with the awful
news of a child's diagnosis with
leukemia
or a mom forced to battle against breast
cancer
an accident that leaves loved ones
unable to live the life
they've always known it stops your heart
it stops your heart it wrenches
your entire world right off its axis
when that happens
and many of you know that from your own
personal experiences
believe me i know the feeling and too
many american families do as well
in that moment the very last thing on
your mind
the very last thing should be on your
mind is whether you can afford the
treatment
a for the affordable care act was
created to put a stop
to that in humanity it was created to
ensure that families
thrust into their worst nightmare of
their lives could focus
not only not on money but on the fight
that really matters
obamacare is a law that every american
should be proud of
it's why people with pre-existing
conditions are protected in this country
it's a law that delivered vital coverage
as i said before for 20 million
americans
who did not have coverage it's a law
that reduced prescription drug price
costs
for nearly 12 million seniors
it's a law that saved lives and spared
countless families from financial ruin
so this effort to bypass
the will of the american people the
verdict of the courts in the past the
judgments of congress
in my view is simply cruel and
needlessly divisive
regardless of the outcome of this case i
promise you this
beginning on january 20th the vice
president-elect harris and i
we're going to do everything in our
power to ease the burden of health care
on you
and your families i promise you that as
i said i will protect your health care
like i protect
like as in my own family we've been
unfortunately
significant consumers of health care
that starts by building on the
affordable care act
with the dramatic expansion of health
care coverage
and bold steps to lower health care
costs
my transition team will soon be starting
its work
to flesh out the details so that we can
hit the ground running
tackling costs increasing access
lowering the price of prescription drugs
families are reeling right now
particularly the reporters in this room
and others listening you've interviewed
a lot of these people around the country
as you've gone all over the
world all over the country enduring
illnesses faced with risky choices
losing their
employer plans and droves already 10
million have already lost their employer
plans
they need a lifeline and they need it
now
they should have to hold their breath
they shouldn't be in that position
waiting to see if the supreme court is
going to wrench away
the peace of mind they've come to now
rely on
so we're going to get right to work i
promise you
addressing the issues that families are
are talking about around the kitchen
tables this morning
making sure that they can get bed
tonight with the peace of mind that they
deserve
and fulfilling our moral obligation to
ensure that
here in america health care is a right
for all
not a privilege for a few so come
january
we're going to work quickly with the
congress to dramatically ramp up health
care protections
get americans universal coverage lower
health care costs
as soon as humanly possible
that's the promise i make to you we're
going to fight
for your family's health coverage the
same way we fight for our own family's
health coverage
we want every single american to know if
you're sick
if you're struggling if you're worried
about how you're going to
get going to get through the day we will
not abandon you that is a promise
will not leave you to face these
challenges alone
we're going to get through this we're
going to get through it together
and we're going to build a healthcare
system that puts you and your families
first
and that every american can be proud of
i want to thank you all for listening
may god bless you may god keep you safe
in this coveted environment
and may god protect our troops now i'm
told that we're going to have
you're going to we're going to take five
questions thereabout
okay
thank you mr president-elect during the
campaign
you said you were not naive about how
difficult it would be to
unite the country it's now three days
after
you were projected as the
president-elect the
president himself says he has won this
election his own administration has not
moved forward to give you access to what
you need to do to begin
the work of your transition just a few
minutes ago the secretary of state when
asked if he would
cooperate with a smooth transition he
said there will be a smooth transition
to a second
trump administration i wonder if you
have a message for the president who may
well be watching right now
and how do you expect to be able to work
with republicans when so many
have thus far refused to even
acknowledge your victory well first of
all uh we are already beginning
the transition we're well underway and
uh
the ability uh for uh the administration
in any way by failure to recognize us
against
our win uh does not uh
change the dynamic at all what we're
able to do
we've announced yesterday as you know
the health
group that we put together today we're
going to be going moving along
in a consistent manner
putting together our administration the
white house and
reviewing who we're going to pick for
the cabinet positions
and nothing's going to stop that and uh
and so i'm confident that uh the fact
that they're not willing to acknowledge
we want at this point
is uh not of much consequence in our
planning and what we're able to do
between now
and january 20th response to secretary
pompeo and i also
i also wonder you warned during the
campaign that as the walls closed in on
the president he would behave more
erratically yesterday he fired his
defense secretary
on twitter are you worried that he's
disabling the government and
what are you saying to the world leaders
who are calling you at this point about
the situation here well first of all uh
i'm letting them know that america is
back uh we're going to be back in the
game it's not american alone
number one i've got had the opportunity
to speak
with now six world leaders
and uh and the response has been
very fulsome energetic
and they're all looking forward to being
able
to from great britain to france
to germany to uh canada
et cetera and ireland um so
i i feel good about the ability to i
said when we
announced that the next president is
going to inherit a divided country
and a world in disarray the reception
and welcome we've gotten around the
world from our allies and our friends
has been real
i'm having a number of other calls to
return and uh
so i feel confident that we're going to
be able to uh
um put the america put america back in
the place of respect that it had before
mr president-elect senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
has suggested today that he may not
recognize
the outcome of this election until the
electoral college meets
next month have you spoken to your
longtime
friend in the senate mr mcconnell
and what do you make of his specific
comments
over the last 24 hours i haven't had a
chance to speak to mitch
my expectation is that i will do that
not too distant future
i think that the whole republican
party has been put in a position with a
few notable exceptions of uh
um being
mildly intimidated by the sitting
president
but there's only one president at a time
he's president
we're going to have the electoral
college will be making their judgment
in december it'll be announced in early
january
but in the meantime i hope to get a
chance to speak to mitch if i could
follow up without transition funding
will you be able to
go through with a proper uh transition
that's needed
would you like access to the pdb and
will you
authorize legal action or would that be
too divisive do you believe i
we can get through without uh
the uh the funding uh we're in a
position that uh
we feel very good about our there's
nothing that slows up our efforts to put
things together
obviously the pdb would be useful but
it's not necessary i'm not the sitting
president now
and so we don't see anything in slowing
us down quite frankly
thank you
thank you mr president-elect and
congratulations to you both
have you tried to reach out at all to
the president and if he is watching
right now
what would you say to him mr president
look forward to speaking with you
and you say that you are being able to
move ahead without interruption but
to jeff's point presumably at some point
you will need access to more classified
information to
secure facilities and the like what
options are you considering how will you
move ahead if the president continues to
refuse to concede
well look access
to classified information is uh
is useful but i'm not a position to make
any decisions
on those issues anyway there's one as i
said one president at a time
and he will be president until january
20th
it would be nice to have it but it's not
critical and
that's we're just going to proceed the
way we have we're going
we're gonna do exactly what we'd be
doing if he had conceded
and said we've won which we have
uh and so there's nothing really
changing but not ruling out legal action
no i don't see a need for a legal action
uh quite frankly
i think the legal action is uh you're
seeing it uh
play out the actions he's taking
and so far there is no evidence of any
of the assertions made
by the president or secretary of state
pompeo
secretary of state pompeo
thank you mr president-elect uh
democrats are on track to lose a handful
of seats in the house of representatives
um that could make it harder to pass
legislation with just democratic votes
i'm just curious how does that impact
your plans
for what priorities you think you can
get through this congress
especially if the senate remains in gop
control
and during the lame duck will you be
coordinating with speaker pelosi on how
she should be negotiating with
republicans
well i've spoken to the leader and i've
spoken to the
minority leader in the house and uh one
of the urgent things that need be done
is people need relief right now
right now small businesses people who
are about to be evicted from their homes
because they can't pay their mortgage
unemployment insurance you know what's
going to happen is you're going to see
what people don't realize is the failure
to provide
state and local assistance you're going
to see police officers
firefighters first responders laid off
and i think the pressure is
is going to build but the fact is that
i would hope that the president at least
has the
sensitivity and knowledge you know that
a lot of people are in real trouble
right now between now and the time we
get elected till we get sworn in
and so it's my hope and expectation i
i'm sure that the
majority the speaker of the house as
well as the minority leader
are working right now into the
priorities they have laid out
but do you plan to be active in those
negotiations working with speaker pelosi
to
represent democrats on the table well i
they we've been talking and they know my
views and uh
and i support what they're doing and
then my second question was about the
senate
do you plan to campaign in georgia
before your inauguration to help
democrats in the two runoff races there
as they try to flip the senate
and uh how important is a democratic
held senate to your agenda well
obviously it'd be much better if we had
uh a tie in the senate which means that
this place doesn't become incredibly
important beyond what she already is
but uh we're gonna do anything we can
that they think we can do to help
and does the democratic senate help your
cabinet chances that does that
uh change how you consider who you
nominate to cabinet posts
no i don't think so i i i take uh
mcconnell at his word i understand he
said that he will make it clear who he's
prepared to support not support and
that's a negotiation
that i'm sure will have look one of the
things that
that i would do as as president
elect and when i become president is lay
out to
the republicans as well as the democrats
who we intend to
name for each cabinet position i hope
we're able to be in a position to let
people know
at least a couple that we want before
thanksgiving and we'll just work this
out
look i am i am not
a pessimist as you know and i think
there are
enough republicans who have already
spoken out but i think there will be
many more
not many more there'll be a larger
number
once the election is declared
and i'm sworn in to be able to get
things done i think they understand for
example i
can't imagine there not being a
willingness
on the part of republicans they're going
to be significant pressure to deal with
health care
their own constituencies are in that
position so i i'm not
i i think we can get a lot done thank
you
sir what do you say to the americans
that are anxious over the fact that
president trump has yet to concede and
what that might mean for the country
well um i just think it's an
embarrassment
um quite frankly uh the only thing that
uh
how can i say this tactfully i think
it will not
help the president's legacy i think that
i know from my discussions with foreign
leaders thus far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and
endured and uh but i think at the end of
the day
uh you know it's all going to come to
fruition
on january 20th and between now and then
i hope an expectation is that the
american people are
do know do understand that there has
been a transition
even among uh republicans who
are people who voted for the president i
understand the sense of
loss i get that but i think
the majority of the people who voted for
the president a lot voted for him
a significantly smaller number but a lot
voted for him
i think they understand that we have to
come together i think they're ready to
unite and i believe we can pull the
country
out of this uh
bitter um politics that we've seen
for the last uh last five six seven
years
and just to follow up on a previous
question how do you expect to work with
republicans if they won't even
acknowledge you as
president-elect they will
they will thank you all so very much
would you take